good evening everybody thank you for
being here appreciate you coming out
you've got a full schedule here we want
to go ahead and get our evening started
before we do of course we would like to
make a couple of announcements if you
would like to donate to the families and
the victims you were able to make a
donation tonight at this table here to
the behind the stage the donation is
100% of those donations will go to the
families it will be through the Gilroy
foundation unfortunately all they can
take tonight is cash there will also be
a account set up if you want to donate
at a later time by credit card or other
means you can contact the Gilroy
Foundation and do just that in order to
make this evening work there's been a
lot of donations in order to pull this
evening off and we just want to make
sure to mention a couple of folks who
donated the candles that was Walmart and
Nob Hill Starbucks donate the Kanaka are
the cups for those candles and so we're
grateful that the community is coming
together all to support one another and
that's really what this event is about
tonight like to see a show of hands of
everybody who is at the festival over
the weekend most everybody here and I
know that all of us probably have some
story to share a story of what if what
if I had just taken two extra minutes to
go over to the vineyard booth or over to
that over to that concert what if I had
left five minutes later what if what if
I'd walk down that path or what if I
just delayed even 30 seconds but I have
been in the way of one of those bullets
that took down 15 of our residents and
guests sadly 15 people were wounded
three have passed away this is a
devastating time for our community but
like many other communities before us we
know that the residents of gourry will
come together well grow stronger through
this will be better because of it not
bitter because of it
and so right now I would like to as we
get started again to thank you all for
being here letting you know that we're
doing this in honor of those individuals
who were wounded and those individuals
who died as we get started I would like
to introduce pastor Brad Shore from
community Christian Gilroy to come up
and say an invocation thank you do it
pray with me
Heavenly Father we are just asking your
blessing over this night as we come
together we need you we know that you're
a God who draws close to the
brokenhearted tonight we certainly as a
community open our hearts to those who
have lost loved ones in this tragedy but
we need your guidance we are so grateful
for the police officers who stood in the
line of fire for us may you bless them
may you protect them as they protect us
display their courage God we come before
you now to and ask we want to know how
can Gilroy as a community find a way to
be part of the solution in this nation
to be able to bring peace to our country
at a time of turmoil we need you we ask
your blessing amen
thank you Pastor we can start now we're
met introduce Angelo Toronto she was the
voice of San Jose and she's going to
come up and sing our National Anthem
oh say can you see
by the dawn's early light what so
proudly we hailed at the twilight's last
gleaming whose broad stripes and bright
stars through the perilous fight o'er
the ramparts we watched were so
gallantly streaming
[Music]
[Music]
yeah brother night that our flag was
[Music]
still there
[Music]
oh say does that star-spangled
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
okay I'd like to introduce our mayor the
mayor of Gilroy mayor Roland Velasco
[Applause]
welcome everybody can you guys all hear
me okay my voice is starting to go I've
been doing a lot of talking the last 24
hours
what amazing 24 hours it's been people
Gilroy you guys are the heart and soul
of the community
I want all of you to know that the
entire City Council is praying for the
community yeah we gather here tonight in
this very impromptu vigil so that the
community can come together and process
their feelings process their thoughts
talk to each other because at the end of
the day maybe not today maybe not
tomorrow but there will be a day when we
start to heal and start to move on with
our lives and the reason for that is
because we cannot let the bastard that
did this tear us down the person that
did this took something from us they
took a small town festival that has
generated millions of dollars over the
last 41 years they took that from us he
took that from us and we even though it
will take time for us to heal we may
never know the true motives of the
individual but we know that Guillory is
strong that the strength of the people
is all of you and we will overcome I am
so pleased to see so many young kids out
here because I think as the adults we
have a responsibility to help talk to
them to try to figure out how
to help them process their feelings as
well now for most of today I have been
in one meeting or another and the
longest meeting I had was with a group
of firefighters as we were internally
discussing the trauma that we had gone
through and it occurred to me that as
much as our police and firefighters need
our support we need the support from
each other because the trauma the anger
that we all feel we need to be able to
process that so that we can move on I'm
not going to speak there much longer but
I do want to say that that it's the
mayor of Gilroy I'm not trained for this
kind of stuff it's been a shock over the
last 24 hours
but to see all of you here tonight I am
just so proud to be your man thank you
[Applause]
and I'd like to introduce state senator
bill bonding who represents Gilroy good
evening I want to thank you all for
being here this evening we're here to
mourn the loss of the lives that were
taken and we're here to send feeling
blessings to those that are in hospitals
and we're here to reaffirm the strength
of the community of Gilroy that stands
together in good times we stand together
in tough times but I want to acknowledge
mayor Roland Velasco and the chief of
police Smithee the leadership this
community has shown at the time of the
crisis and in the aftermath of the
crisis as the mayor said there's no
training manual for responding to this
type of tragedy the decisive response of
law enforcement saved many lives but for
those families who lost loved ones
that's not what they're thinking of
they're thinking of the loss and we as
Gilroy pull together not only to mourn
those losses but to support each other I
know that your mayor was one of the
responders not by choice but by
circumstance and participated and some
of the triage trying to save lives at
the time as did other first responders
there's members of the media here this
evening many have asked what are we
going to do what's the political
response and my response is we're here
this evening to mourn these losses we're
here this evening to support each other
we will take away from this experience
appropriate actions in the future but
you know in a few days the TV trucks
will be gone but the tragedy will still
be hanging over Gilroy and our our
neighboring communities and the tragedy
is enhanced I think because this
happened at the Gilroy Garlic Festival a
festival where people donate literally
thousands of hours of volunteer time to
support local nonprofits it's it's a
model not just in this state but
nationally people look at how the garlic
festival has grown and how its organized
I was at the first garlic festival my
wife and I lived in San Juan Bautista it
was in that field by the house off of
101 there's only a few hundred people
there and you look at how it's growing
it's growing with the strength of this
community it's grown with the strength
of the volunteers no errant mentally ill
person is going to take the strength of
Gilroy away from Gilroy it's going to
make us stronger
I want to also acknowledge those that
have organized rapidly for this evening
I do want to thank the media that has
been here both covering the news but
also offering their comfort as human
beings
Assemblymember Robert Revis asked me to
convey his support for the community
he's returning home from overseas travel
he called me last night and asked that I
give his communication of support to the
community as does Senator on a Caballero
an assembly member Mark stone and I also
spoke today with our president of the
Senate Tony Atkins who offered any
support that we in the state Senate can
offer to the community of Gilroy as does
the office of emergency services the
coming together of different agencies
the first responders and now people that
are pulling together to help people
manage the pain the sense of loss and
I'll just close in the memory of those
that we lost when we returned to session
on August 12th I will be a journey the
California State Senate session in the
memories of those who lives were lost so
senselessly young people a young child
this is not normal and our response has
to make sure this never happens again
in our community or any other community
Thank You Gilroy for your strength thank
you for the comfort we're giving each
other
[Applause]
we're gonna ask some some folks from the
community to come up and speak and I
want to bring them forward and have them
come on up Kelly Ramirez else'll of
Lopez Angelo Toronto I think we have a
microphone and we're gonna we're going
we're going to move that forward we're
going to ask those speakers not to come
up on the stage but actually to come
forward to the front of the stage and
we're gonna have your lineup right here
so we can actually save time we're going
to ask those speakers to hold their
comments to about two minutes one of the
things I thought I'm going is the
comment that was made years ago and it
said it's not what lies behind us and
what lies before us but what lies within
us that truly matters and what lies
within this community is people of
people of passion people who are
compassionate people who are strong
people are resilient people have
resolved and so we know that no matter
what happens in our community our
community will come together to stand
strong and to be able to overcome these
kinds of events will link arms we'll
stand shoulder to shoulder and you'll
see tonight as these individuals come
forward to say a few words and these are
the people we're talking about much like
all of you many of you who at the
festival at the time the shooting
occurred actually ran into action began
to help others assisted those who were
in need help those who were wounded and
participated in heroic efforts making
sure that our community members were
safe and so now I'd like to introduce a
few people to come forward the first one
being Kelly Ramirez she is being invited
to speak as a community member she was
at the festival at the time the shooting
occurred
Kelly Ramirez
[Applause]
we hear about the victims
a six-year-old boy who should be
splashing and sprinklers learning to
ride a bike and playing catch with his
dad a 13 year old girl who should be
experiencing her first crush
sleepovers with her girlfriends and
shopping for new school clothes a young
man in his 20s beginning his career
perhaps spending a little too much on a
bar tab and ubers feeling his
independence
indescribable tragedies lives cut short
families fractured and lost in grief
we hear about those with injuries some
who will spend months recovering many
missing out on plans made before this
tragedy and lives forever changed the
victims and their families have the love
prayers and support of the Gilroy
community in addition to the victims
we have survivors we are all survivors
of the trauma of this tragedy
I recall the people I was sheltering
within our tent the paralyzing fear of
the mothers whose children were
somewhere in the park but not with them
high school cheerleaders huddled
together in fear the two young children
under the age of five who were being
hushed without understanding what was
happening their parents with fear in
their eyes who focused on remaining calm
for their young children and our tenth
of survivors was not unique this
scenario was being played out in several
locations throughout the park there were
those who ran for their lives there were
those who were not at the park but had
family and friends there
every one of us in this community is now
a survivor even the brave first
responders especially the heroic Gilroy
police officers who risked their lives
to protect so many
and their families who knew their loved
ones had selflessly rushed into danger
and also waited anxiously to learn of
their safety but I have faith in the
Gilroy community I believe that knowing
we are not alone will give each of us
the strength to move beyond this I don't
believe this tragedy will define us but
I hope it will be a defining moment as
we move forward in the healing process
let us draw inspiration from the victims
let us honor their memories by taking a
moment to slow down move away from our
distractions and put more time into
making the effort to reach out call a
family member take a hike with a friend
be available and be present as
individuals we will heal but
collectively we will rise let this be
how we are defined we are survivors
we are Gilroy strong
[Applause]
hello my name is Elsa Lopez I'm from San
Jose I have a non-profit a mother's
voice victims of violence I work with
the community of San Jose and I came out
together and Morgan Hill to help out
families that lose a loved one through
street violence to violence and I came
out here tonight to support Gilroy and
the community
we all know that with this tragedy that
happened and what was meant for evil
became out of love look around and see
how many people are here
look at this community coming together
in love you know we are broken today and
the families are even more broken but if
I ask I ask you to pray for the families
pray for strength because the families
aren't shocked right now they're in
disbelief they wish they were dreaming
right now some families are regretting
going to the festival right now they are
planning funerals further families as we
roll out here as a community remember
those families that are planning
funerals right now keep them in prayer
they're gonna need your strength they're
gonna need your prayers what I teach in
San Jose and would I teach the mothers
that deal with violence and lose their
families to violence I tell them and I
want you guys to all hear this you might
have silenced our children but you did
not silence us we are their voice we
have to come as a community and be that
voice for them talk to these young
adults reach out to the youth
and give them understanding speak to
them they are our future and I thank you
all for inviting me to speak and I asked
that you say prayers for the family and
that you as a community come together
again what was meant for evil we stepped
on that evil with love and we are all
out here with love for our community
again be that voice for these families
for your community stand up no more
violence in this community speak up
please thank you next Tuesday is
national night out and there'll be
families that are still coping with the
shock and the tragedies are going out
but you come out to national night out
as a community we stay together as one
as you are tonight thank you
[Applause]
you know one of the things that was the
on that Sunday afternoon when the shots
rang out the support that we got from
mutual aid the surrounding ceremony the
surrounding areas with police and
Sheriff and and the various support that
we got from other agencies was
incredible the support from the
communities around us for the to the
south or to the north is very helpful in
encouraging in fact we have tonight some
of our City Council members from Morgan
Hill and I know that they're here would
you mind raising your hand if you're one
of the City Council members from Morgan
Hill we appreciate you being here thank
you so much this point in time I'd like
to introduce one of the Morgan Hill City
Council members Renee spring
[Applause]
good evening everyone my name is rene
spring and the mayor for a time of your
neighboring city of Morgan Hill just a
few weeks back we had the similar
gathering in our city our hearts were
broken then my heart is broken again the
event that she had yesterday was not
just in any event for Kilroy only many
of our young ones residents from Morgan
Hill helped volunteer and visited as
well life will go on one day I didn't
sleep well last night that's I didn't
sleep well five weeks ago when we had a
shooting at the Ford store Morgan Hill
it is heartbreaking and my condolences
go out to the families of those who lost
their lives yesterday and to those who
got hurt and are still in the hospital
healing and to those who witnesses and
had to run and are still trying to
process what really has happened things
like that don't happen in Gilroy they
don't happen in Morgan Hill but they do
happen but you know what I look around
there is hope you are here you did not
stay at home being fearful don't let
them win we will win we will come out of
this stronger you have a lot of friends
in Morgan Hill and we will come down
here over and over again to be with you
to celebrate with you to celebrate life
there is hope without hope we cannot
live so you you and you you all need to
give hope to everyone around you if your
loved ones are hard before you leave
home or before you go to bed it is
needed things can change quickly but
again you are our hope you are what I
believe in and thank you all for coming
tonight
[Applause]
so I asked mark Turner if I could
introduce our next speaker let me read
to you and I hope our next speaker
doesn't get too upset at this let me
read to you some text messages that were
going back and forth in the middle of
everything that was going on I'm
receiving emails and text messages from
not just locally but across the country
and even Australia and in the middle of
everything I get this message I know we
have units on the scene but please let
me know if there's anything that we can
do to help emergency medical response
police or otherwise sending prayers I
respond with thank you appreciate the
thoughts and prayers working on a press
release he comes back and says we could
get more paramedics or police down there
if you need them just say the word I
respond with not needed at this time
according to fire chief we have a San
Jose lieutenant in the command vehicle
and plenty of EMTs and police on scene
thank you his response was absolutely in
addition to the manhunt San Jose PD will
also remain Offutt role to help GPD so
that they could get folks back on shift
now the person that I'm trading these
text messages with is San Jose Mayor Sam
Locarno we had so many different
agencies contacting Gilroy and sending
their fire and police down here
literally from from up north and I think
we had almost every jurisdiction in the
south coming over here to Gilroy
but it's because of the leadership of
Sam Locarno people like state senator
bill Monning the assembly member of
Robert Revis congresswoman zoloft friend
and and senator Feinstein have been
reaching out to me congressman Jimmy
Panetta they have all contacted me
wanting what's very best for Gilberry
and offering their help in any way and
so I just wanted to take a moment to
introduce San Jose Mayor Sam latardo a
friend is doing thank you there I know
there's a lot of pain right now in this
community and I'm honored to join you to
be here to share with you that your pain
is not alone that your pain is a pain
felt by families throughout our Bay Area
and certainly in San Jose as we learned
of the loss of young Stephen young Kayla
who says a families mourn their loss as
a grappling the family members who are
still in the hospital we are feeling
this pain together all of us
but I know that although the pain is not
constrained by city limits nor is the
inspiration the strength that I feel
here in this Gilroy community and I want
to say thank you for allowing me to be
here to witness this people who are
passionate about coming together at a
time of such intense grief about pulling
together to help one another in any way
you can you are a model for all of us
and I will bring your gift your strength
to San Jose please continue to stay
strong and be the inspiration for all of
us thank you
Thank You mayor and I like to introduce
neshama odds all this is with the
Interfaith community of South County
[Applause]
so we're a bit overwhelmed so bear with
me as I read a statement on behalf of
the South County the Interfaith
community of the South County I'm a
resident of Gilroy myself and looking
out and standing here with my fellow
community members it's very hard as a
unified group the South the Interfaith
community of the South County extends
our deepest and heartfelt sympathies to
the victims and other who have been
affected by the active shooter situation
which occurred at the Gilroy Garlic
Festival on Sunday to the parade first
responders who acted swiftly and
decisively to eliminate the threat and
minimize the casualties we express our
thanks and our overwhelming gratitude of
the selfless service which saved many
many lives to the families of the
victims and others deeply affected by
these tragic events we offer our sincere
condolences we reach out to you in
spirit of support and we grieve with you
as well in the wake of your loss
as members of the faithful congregations
across South County area we extend to
you our love our prayers and blessings
of peace and know that you are not alone
sincerely the congregations of the
Interfaith community of South County
care why we are strong thank you
next is City Council member of Gilroy
Peter Lorre Oh muñoz
[Applause]
I remember the very first garlic
festival that I went to and I was
volunteering in gourmet alley and I was
helping move trays of hot garlicky
calamari and five minutes into my shift
I immediately burned my hand and for
thirty minutes I'd to take some time
with my burned hand and a cup of ice
water and I remember looking out over
the scene playing in front of me and
there were people in garlic hats there
were volunteers running to and fro with
hot sandwiches and there were scores and
scores of people more than I had ever
seen in Gilroy together at one spot and
I'll be honest I at first I thought this
is a little ridiculous but I soon
learned that was the best of Gilroy
right there the Garlic Festival is our
annual showcase to the world and to
ourselves about the best that we can be
the speakers have already addressed how
we raise money for different community
organizations they've talked about the
cultural impact that this event has and
the showcase for diversity that it
offers and it really was the best of
Gilroy and that was never more on
display yesterday with those volunteers
with those visitors and guests who
responded so admirably in the face of
cruelty and violence to help and support
one another and that was especially
exhibited with our first responders who
again in the face of danger thought only
of serving others and not their own self
protection or preservation
this reminds me it's a stark reminder
but it's a reminder nonetheless that
together we are stronger than anything
that tries to divide us now you'll see
some people out in the crowd tonight who
are wearing the shirt that I am where it
says Gilroy strong and those have to be
more than just words we have to speak
those words we have to believe those
words and then we have to live those
words so with me right now I'm going to
say we are and I want you to say Gilroy
strong and we're going to do this three
times because we're going to take that
first step together to say these words
to believe these words and then to live
these words so please join me now we are
Gilroy strong we are we are yes we are
thank you
[Applause]
council member laural Munoz mentioned
the first responders and we have one of
those first responders here tonight
would you please welcome sergeant Jason
Smith with the Gilroy Police Department
[Music]
on behalf of the aware Police Department
thank you for that so I'm gonna tell you
a story I was walking to my car tonight
and I heard about this vigil and I said
to myself I want to come out and and see
how the turnout is and I stood in the
back and it looked at the turnout and
it's very moving and I can't tell you
how much the police department
appreciates the support and the
community appreciates the support so
thank you
I was one of the first responders
yesterday and I was an experiment for
you guys to know the amount of bravery
the amount of compassion and the amount
of professionalism these officers had we
hurt for all of you our heart is broken
and there's really no words
we are so proud to serve this community
and we're gonna continue to serve this
community because we love you guys we
love you guys our hearts go out to all
of you the victims their survivors the
people that were affected this community
and like I said we just wanted to let
you know that we love you god bless and
we'll heal together thank you thank you
sergeant
like many of you I too was in the
festival the evening that the shooting
began and it was interesting to see as
many people were fleeing the scene to
watch our first responders rush into
harm's way as sergeant Smith stated they
do it they do it that's their job they
take an oath and of willingness to lay
down their lives for the public's for
the public's life and so we so much
appreciate our first responders can we
hear it for them one more time
mount our TechSmith brought some
information that we could pass along to
you this information is at the table
here in the back it's some information
about the DA's office local agencies
Open Family Assistance Center to help
Gilroy shooting victims but you need
some additional information you can pick
that up at the table after the service
here tonight our next speaker I'd like
to introduce is Mary peace you know it's
so wonderful to see everybody here and
seeing us all United together so if you
would like I'll have you repeat the the
lines with me as I say this prayer I
offer you peace
I offer you love I offer you friendship
I see your beauty
I hear your need I feel your feelings
my wisdom flows from the highest source
I salute the source in you
let us work together for unity and love
and that's Donnie's prayer for peace
thank you with a xpeke right I think
I'll just stick with her first name cuz
I could I could really ruin this if I
try the last name peanut do have that
right you know you know something before
I read what I wrote I just want to point
out that you know when one part of your
body hurts or something's wrong with one
part of your body the entire body feels
the effects and I feel looking out all
these people are all feeling the effects
of this one tragedy my name is Hannah
and I'm a member of the South Valley
Islamic community
will happen yesterday was treacherous in
his heartbreaking but I think most of
all it's stupefied to think here in our
backyard innocent lives were taken from
us too soon and without justice acts of
violence or fear are fueled only by fear
not courage or strength strength and
courage is defined by this this right
here friends families and strangers
coming together in support of each other
in the face of a tragedy but I'm gonna
be extremely transparent today I think
just like many of us here are wondering
I wonder when will this terror end from
communities near far and ours I appeal
to our elected officials as a
matriculating law student who's
neglected to use their legislative power
to less to sensibly respond to these
massacres I ask just as a human when is
enough enough policymakers need to start
taking notice and acting it is long
overdue but every day the call for
serious action to address gun violence
causing death in every corner of our
country grows louder we cannot and will
not lose hope that change is possible
our next speaker is Karin Kyra
Lewandowski
[Applause]
hello my name is Kara I wrote something
as well before I read what I wrote I
look around here today and I realized
that there are so many people and it
amazes me that from one incident so many
people all come together to recognize
what has happened
yesterday when I learned of this
incident my heart was completely
shattered so many people were out there
at this festival just trying to have fun
with their family so many lives were
then changed forever
we go out to festivals in our own
hometown okay we cannot fun with our
family our friends even I loved ones and
we do this because we feel safe it's our
backyard pretty much but then when
something like this happens it just
changes everything we don't feel safe
anymore and we should definitely always
feel safe in our own backyards even at
festivals just trying to enjoy time with
our families all of these young kids
will never be able to unsee what was
witnessed yesterday I was not there at
the festival but I know so many people
who were there I checked up on everyone
I knew and one of my friends told me I
saw the bullet hit the ground right next
to me and I was scared and I ran for my
life
this festival has been going on for
about 41 years and this is the first
time something like this has ever
happened how are you supposed to explain
to your children when they ask you how
your day was and this happened you can't
really explain that to someone so young
my heart aches so much I was reading the
news and I had read that after the after
the first after the shooter had shot the
first victim he walked over there and
asked are you okay it got a super
upsetting and I also read that someone
yelled why are you doing this and he
yelled back because I'm very angry just
because you're angry doesn't mean you
should take this out on so many innocent
people's lives so far three people have
passed away a six year old a 13 year old
and a guy in his twenties they had their
whole entire life ahead of them and now
they they didn't even get to go home
yesterday
this is super heartbreaking into all
these people all they wanted to do was
go out and enjoy the day they never
thought that someone was going to come
to a family festival and do what they
did we should all feel safe out in
public and it feels so and it is so sad
that those people aren't fearing and
going going outside anymore because of
what happened here today
let's take a moment for everyone who
lost their life yesterday and all of
those families and victims that were
injured I also want to take a moment and
thank everyone for showing up tonight it
really means a lot to the community and
all of the victims family always know
that you were never alone in any
situation like this
[Applause]
next is Richard Alvarez
[Applause]
my name is Richard Alvarez I am a
student recovery director on the behalf
of cathedral faith in San Jose and also
our campus here in Gilroy first of all
let me say that I want to give my
condolences the family who lost their
loved ones if it families that there's
their family members were injured also
want to say to that on the behalf that
they will fade that we you guys are in
our prayers from the leadership of this
city to the families to those who serve
this city and to know that we care and
that we're concerned for your healing
and what you're going through and your
pain that you are experiencing today as
community I just like to encourage
everyone to stay strong and to know that
as you stay strong
then you'll then healing will begin the
process and sometimes the process can be
painful as a recovery pastor I work with
students I've seen adults that go
through a process of paying hurt but I
also know too that on the other end as
you walk through it there is healing I
also want to encourage you here in the
South County from